aignan thomas des friches a probablement
été un des plus grands collectionneurs
de son temps un des plus grands au
relais année aussi mais surtout un grand
négociant qui a fait fortune dans le
commerce triangulaire d'angola vers les
antilles puis vers la loire ont
transporté à la fois du sucre des épices
mais également des esclaves
[Musique]
en 1751 son frère lui ramène des
antilles un esclave le paul qui va
entrer à son service jusqu'à la fin de
sa vie en 1760 camping elle va venir
faire le portrait de son ami des friches
à orléans il va également faire celui de
paul et pour cause les deux hommes ne
sont pas simplement maîtres et esclaves
m et domestiques mais surtout deux
grands amis qui vont rester très proche
jusqu'à la fin de leur existence
si bien que en 1760 quand pigalle le
grand sculpteur de huy 15 à venir rendre
visite à son ami des friches
il réalisera non seulement le portrait
de des friches
mais avant tout le portrait de son ami
le paul
[Musique]
c'est la traite des noirs est évidemment
au coeur de ce commerce triangulaire de
belles histoires d'amitié en as
également et c'est aujourd'hui ce que
raconte ce bus qui témoigne de la grande
amitié de des friches et de son
serviteur
[Musique]
oh